so my name is Jae Beom Jo and I'm
walking into infamy such and there's Yun
Chao there will give some portion of my
talk today the title of talk is advanced
in grabs and network so I'm mostly
talking about some enhancement in late
recent version of Mathematica in
graphene Network also giving some new
functions for upcoming version of
America and some future plan so first of
all Aris start with multi graph and this
is not new as you know I think if you
are here you probably a little bit
familiar with the crap so multi graph is
crap is multi at G like we share the
example here we have multiple HT 3 1
here 1 3 1 3 1 3 so far so good
it looks nice and we notice all the same
edges and now we want to distinguish
these multi edges by giving different
labels and see what happened the thing
is now is showing all first instead of
this one second third
why is that it's like a multiplayer like
twins right sometimes this all looks
same so mathmatica try to giving some
different quantity for third second but
you don't know who's who so it decide to
little bit fair so giving same thing to
everyone so this is what happens so
because if we have 3 1 3 3 1 how do you
know so in the new version of
Mathematica okay so here's the 3 edges 1
2 1 2 1 2 so what we gonna do is whoops
you see here some kind of tag so we
introduced tag
so each HJ can keep the clipped with
tags which distinguish the multi gray
multi edges so so how we do that so here
is the traditional HJ undirected edge
Sigma 1 and we introduce third argument
which call tag so in this case tag of
this first three one me and brother now
we can know we can give some identity so
for example I cashier now we can label
keeping the different label for same
edges it's not really saying it has a
tag now so so here this is one way the
defining the tagged multi edges and
giving some identity and if you don't
like just adding tag for each edges we
have some new function to help you
define we call oops what happened okay I
we have to switch my slider there are
some some things going on let me just
sorry about this
okay yep
this should be fine
okay now we have better so we call a
cheat a graph this is function so what
it does is we use same age graph so like
a its image grab input formulas so
labeled 3 and verse 3 1 we didn't
specify tag but if you use each tag
graph it automatically giving tag to
each edges so now you see here and like
even you can specify different colors
and for example if you just see the I
will show later ok and then so right
here so edgy tag the graph 1 2 1 2 2 3
and you see the difference if you put
out at least now you see tag for each
edges so it is automatically given to
impurities and we have some component
the function related to a cheat a graph
showing each degree of Q so it will
control whenever your graph is tagged
and a cheat tags giving you list of 80
tags
the position is correspond to at least
and another usage of already two tags
1/2 min between vertex one and two
keeping the list of tags at G between
one and two in this case one two one two
yeah we have two edges so you got to a G
tags and you can laid your hand if you
have any questions short questions and
another function here is index a cheater
graph so index h- also create agitated
graph right like this but the difference
is you just need to think about the
relation between grabs and index graph
what index graph does is it de plays
each vertex to index
like you if you have crept with vortex
ABC if your fly index crap you convert a
[ __ ] - 1 2 3
so index edge attack the graph convert
hg tags to index of achieve a tease
so here if you do dots just a cheater
graph as you can see the tag is 1 2 and
this one is 1 so it please different at
least always start from one edge attacks
one to one but if you apply index attack
the graph to grab it looks same graph
but if you threw out at least now you
see 1 2 3 the tags the following index
of edges and H attacked now is 1 2 3 so
depends on your you know workflow you
can either use a cheat a graph or index
data Telegraph
okay next thing is inheritance of
annotations annotations which use 3
properties so what I mean is now we have
some graph with nice style tossing graph
and previous version some of the
functions some operational constructor
if you apply the function G has the nice
styling but this is in version 11
you got the spanning tree but it doesn't
contain any the property annotations
from original graph right this one G we
have in the front no not this
so for example let me just run this
again this is weighted graph but this
spanning tree actually remove the way
it's automatic no I have to learn this
in version 11 but I accidentally learned
EC 12 and this is kind of sneak peak
so in pageant ref same graph and like
you just see all the function and
constructor or some operation will mean
when inherit the uh notations of
original graph like here or Botticelli
and coordinate everything and anyway and
here you can apply the options in
version 11 some of the the graph
function doesn't even accept additional
options and now we apply this principle
inheritance to all over the function in
the graph so you can you know specify
any option and you can just you know get
the options from the original functions
and it's not just preserving the
annotations we also select if we want to
freedom option or not so this is some
usage how we do that so for example if
you the sub graph you see although the
annotations is preserved but like I
don't want to that for some region
episodes your eyes and something then
you can say o notation rules known then
it just remove all the option from
origin to original functions so it
doesn't carry any so it for like it will
not have
yeah empty options and also you say
known but I also want to carry some of
options or annotations like edgy style
and bot x-coordinate then you can say a
chest I inherited part x-coordinate
inherited then you just inherit the edge
style and but x-coordinate so there are
those combination for example ugh here
you just want to a distal lad except 3 -
3 X - 3 - in this case you see this is 3
- it's just only this one inherit
original the options and other things in
new version we introduce some of the new
predicate so like a vortex way to the
grab queue and activated great cure so
we used to have waited a graph cure but
that function return true either
kravitz protects way or edge away it
doesn't even when it little true you
don't know which way the graph has like
vortex or edgy so to distinguish that we
now have vertex awaited the graticule it
only returns true when grab only wine
grape has vortex away so this graph only
etch away so you got the force same
thing for activate a degree of Q force
this is the function but sometimes you
need it and it's very useful and fast
and new vertex labels we introduced some
automatic skin / labeling position so
this is what we used giving so when this
automatically always set of vortex
Labor's after all this is the position
like you said but in new version
for like a subtle embedding we placed it
outside of a circle so giving more
visibility and even like a for spring
logical embedding you see the difference
instead of it above it tried to check
the local neighbor and place the bot X
the label which have most space so like
here right so giving little bit more
visibility for labels yeah but this this
edge is not the path hope so this
probably 411 right so low is it only see
local local neighbors yeah yeah I
expected yes so yeah it's the local
scheme in this case I mean you can make
global scheme but that take more
computation and yeah you don't want to
spend like our poor label placement
engineer and some new layout like rabbit
embedding so basically what it does is
for graph we just put some center center
gravity and to those spring embedding
the energy based embedding and make some
nice grab so older you know it's going
to in the center and new platen skald
index labels this is like a text in text
we see this kind of plot Emilie's so we
just make one so if we I just show one
but the total memory and here we will
introduce more platen writer so this is
like out of the constructor max
connectivity graph and this one the yarn
will increase about these new functions
yeah this is a match connectivity graph
so much contradict graph is given mesh
we want to measure out the connectivity
between the mesh cells so when it's the
that imagine zero actually this is the
points connectivity by lines this is the
accepted and imagine zero then it's the
this is that will give a graph the cells
dimension D that is still a share
ourselves
imagine t minus one so here we also can
give the lighter if they're two cells in
the different dimension when used fronty
win from e then this to tell cells and
connected if they share a dimension R so
let's see a smoke Santos so this is this
is a mango mesh so we want to find a
connection to point conduction by lines
so we went on dimension zero we used the
same word has coordinate photograph and
the food for the mesh so here we won't
find the connection between the cells
the faces and the points and they shared
on the same lines then it will be
connected so this is what we get to the
graph here so let's see some so let's
see some example here give a mesh so
this is the face okay so I won't find
there are adjacent faces around this
place so we can we can press down
computer the the phase connectivity
graphs so compute it then we get later
on
this is graph then we are we are because
this is a graph so we can use the graph
function like adjacency list so get here
so you can see it's very easy we get the
light and three polygons adjacent to
this sales so another new function is
the is that I will talk about is the
expression graph so expression graph
accepted expression so any expression
from the Waffen language here is a small
example here Oh what why is he here
[Music]
again come on okay B and C or whatever
finally okay so this is an expression so
we can get this on the tree graph here
so so but from here we could not see any
sub expression so if we want to see the
sub expression we can use the record
labels automatic then here we will see
the on all the satisfaction like here a
plus a plus the B power of the the co
sightings so sometimes okay we don't
want to expand it a cosine sum
expression so we can use the same form
any static and expression match this
form it will be a leaf it were not
expanded so came here you can see it's
you can see here the cosine things not
expand it so here also we can use a lot
limited the level of the trees here so
just a one level so here I just give
some example either any expression so
you can use the mesh region graph 3d and
like the middle part so we get the
lighter some okay
come play the trees yeah I think that's
it so like I said they are we just
giving some simple example that
interaction with grab functionality and
other area so this case is the using the
grab functionality to others so like a
molecule and we have molecular graphs so
we can convert the molecular structure
to certain graph and using
checking the matrix flood of this
distance matrix or something and even
find position of that and apply this
position to molecular graph to find the
shortest path between two the atoms and
you know this is like using this path we
found we can get a pond based so this is
one simple example how we used great
functionality to other area and next
example is another direction the
opposite direction already so in this
case we have graph and using
optimization functionality we find the
max cop problem a Mossad max problem
like so semi definite optimization is
kind of new optimization function and
then doing some contention we can find
the maximum cut and using that easier to
be just giving them plotting the that
that makes cut communities and so what's
next we we are kind of dividing two area
learnability usability is this kind of
big future plan so learnability what I
mean is we will improve and we are
improving right now the documentation
not just grabbed and some discrete
mathematics so we kind of adding more
examples and improve and you know giving
some some easier idea and more
application into documentation that's
what we are doing also
and we're gonna make more courses so
it's more like in depth then
documentation even like tutorial or some
twitch talk or those things the news
ability so we're gonna keep building
utility functions for using like a
weighty vortex or a telegraph Q is one
of the smaller utility function but that
giving some more useful
use more useful to users in large graphs
what I mean is like logic rap means
something some grab we mesma cannot
handle because it was too big so that
case one of the our plan is called like
Arabic or graph so you story oh crap
not in America in your like podium hard
drive and we just taking some portion of
we then do computation you have object
endo Mathematica but that object is
connected to out of Mathematica so we
can handle some logic refers to another
plane we have and more so we are not
restricted to utility function ladder
graph we will have new functions and
also new improvement of existing
functions so that people today and you
have any questions yes
[Applause]